[Music]
there were so many things that i did
foolishly during that time and i'm not
just talking about like
you know oh you know i wasn't as good at
this thing as i am now it's like no like
there was so much opportunity right
under my nose
and i was blind to it and like one of
the biggest like scary things for me now
is like
what are those things today
that are right in front of me that i'm
too stupid to see just like i was too
stupid to see it seven years ago when i
was doing that other thing
um for example
greg you were in our early mastermind
groups and the founders of calm were
there and they were talking about how
hard it was and how they're just you
know it was just alex it was just kind
of like
yeah it's hard to raise money right now
i'm trying and and we were just like
dude it's cool app man you should stick
with it he's like yeah i'm gonna just
keep going and like that's a two billion
dollar plus company now and we were
helping him like
dude why didn't we cut the check you
were there too i don't know you didn't
cut a check either did you i remember at
the time like if i'm being honest like i
felt that it was too niche
like i was like we were like sean you
and i were focusing on like
we were doing the big stuff stuff that
was going to be yeah exactly
later
he's got the huge company exactly
uh there was so many of those so in our
masterminds itself i think uh loom was
in there that's a billion dollar company
and i remember kind of like trying to
mentor shy and being like
bro like you know don't worry you'll
figure it out maybe it's not this one
but like when you get to your real game
you're gonna be like good because of
this experience you were friends with
him too like did you invest in that like
i missed i missed it was called uh uh
what was it called open test dot co
and that's what loom was originally
and
it you know
it felt like
you know when you're doing your first
startup and
it just feels so shaky because you're
it's your first time doing all this
stuff like that's what
it felt like
and so it was you know and then also the
the narrative at the time was
don't invest in other people's startups
you got if you if you want to make it in
silicon valley you got to give
laser focus so i
you know my mistake in my 20s was i came
to san francisco and
you know i listened to all these vcs
with all their narratives
and i did it and if i were to redo it i
would frankly just be doing what i now
which is doing like what i'm doing now
which is like focused on communities
doing agency services
you know
focusing on niches and and and web you
know yeah just build an experiment and
not have the biggest exits in the world
so there was like 10 examples like that
like i remember alex mccall came over
one day and he we were catching up and
then
he went on to start clear i remember
thinking this guy's [__] amazing um i
should invest in this clear bit thing
and i like went over to his office and
we like hung out i was like about to
meet the guys i was like i love the
energy of this office man like if i just
couldn't do anything besides feel this
office i would be like they're building
a winner in here and that's also like i
don't know if it's a billion it's
multi-hundred million
um and he told me at the end he goes oh
by the way i'm buying up uh
i was like what else are you doing
finally i started asking more questions
like what else are you doing he's like
oh i bought up some stripe shares this
striped shirt is available for like two
billion dollars so i'm buying a bunch of
striped shirts i think it was him maybe
josh buckley is one of them and he's
like i'm buying up stripes for 2 billion
let me know if you want in
and i was like 2 billion to me i was
like well that's like the most a startup
is worth there's like a billion is like
the top of the mountain so like
to me it was like oh there's no upside
left you know i didn't like think from
first principles about like everybody
knew stripe was [__] amazing it was
like the best startup in the whole like
you know in silicon valley
and i had this opportunity to go buy
stripes at 2 billion and i thought how
late i was and i was like man i wish i
could have got in earlier and now like
you know the things i would give for
stripe shares at 2 billion now like it's
like
that's already like
like 100x you know from from there and
that was proven right
forget that then there was all the
services we were using like fur khan
who's my cto he would be like oh this is
a cool cool product let's use this in
our tech stack if i had just invested in
all the bills we were paying for like
software we were using like pagerduty
and elasticsearch and so you know like
one after another those were all
huge winners that were pre-ipo
um so first was investing the second was
like project selection so like you were
talking about greg i did the same thing
i was playing by the rules of like i was
playing by other people's rules
meaning like what was considered cool in
silicon valley was to be like a product
guy
who was building who had like cool
product taste and was building like um
you know like new markets and like going
for the big billion dollar prizes
and then i met sam who was like i'm
writing this newsletter it's free i'm
gonna have like newsletter ads and i was
like yeah but like
are you gonna do a startup someday
like that's how i felt about it right
sam's company
sells for more than more than my company
sold for in the end he goes uh he goes
look you're good but basically like
you're showing up to a knife fight with
a knife and i wish you would show up
with a magic wand that would just murder
the competition i'm like sounded cool
right i was like uh that's a great
analogy that's a cool story but like uh
i don't know man i think
the math kind of i think it might
achieve the desired outcome which i'm
trying to do here which
uh when i started i was just trying to
be financially independent by the age of
30. that was the only goal um and so
so like if i could go back and just
whisper three things about like just
stress just strategy like forget life
advice just strategy advice i would have
said
um
invest in all the smart people you know
like it'll it'll work out if you don't
have the money go convince somebody that
you have a bunch of really smart friends
that they should give you money to
invest in that that would be the first
thing the second is invest in all of the
expenses on your p l so go find all the
places you're spending money and go try
to invest in all those companies that
will also do fantastically well you'll
make more on that than your own company
okay if you really want to do your own
company beyond that fantastic that's
great you're going to build up skills
and you've got a lottery ticket there
that might work
i would have just said
like
don't try to be mark zuckerberg from the
social network like think about what
like like basically just open your eyes
to the problems and the opportunities
that exist today and so like
you know whether it was like e-commerce
or shopify apps or like these sounded
small at the time but they sounded small
because that's where they were early
and like at that time i needed a vc to
like stamp their approval that this was
a good market or a good opportunity
which by that time is pretty late
because what's the vc doing they're
looking at what companies are raising
huge rounds which means like
four years ago those were great
opportunities three years ago those were
great opportunities and so i wish i had
just kind of been more eyes wide open on
like
what projects are available to you and
like the things that sound kind of
nation funny
those are actually better signals for
you than the thing that the vc is saying
is gonna be huge or is already huge
because it's
often um
you know those companies to start are
like you're in a you're in an absolute
dog fight and it's just like one winner
out of 100 is going to emerge versus
other things where like you could
basically take
no no product risks no market risk so
i had a friend vishal tell me this once
he goes i invest in companies with no
product market fit risk
i had never heard somebody say that it
didn't even make sense to me i go what
do you mean like
every startup is product market fit risk
you guys know it's not
like what he goes
he was the one who convinced me to buy
bitcoin initially as well he was like
bitcoin's going to be the you know the
biggest thing in the world he's like i
just put up basically all the money i
have in the bitcoin i was like what the
[__] this is like back in 2005 16 15.
nobody was really saying that back then
so for the product market fit thing he
goes he goes for example i just invested
in a company that's making a robot that
makes pizzas and it makes pizza it makes
a perfect pizza every time 24 7 at a
lower cost than a human being can do it
he goes
i don't know if they can because there's
a ton of engineering risk like they may
not be able to technically do it but if
they can do it there's zero market risk
every pizza shop will want this over
paying an employee to make imperfect
pizzas
only in certain hours call in sick and
blah blah like it for a higher cost
and i was like oh [__] that's true there
are things that have zero market risk
and i was taking like maximum market
risk before so like that's the other
strategy is like
you don't have to take as much market
risk the thing you're doing now greg is
like way less market risk the thing i'm
doing with milk road had like zero
market risk basically and there's just
like there's a lot of money there's
life-changing money that can be made and
a lot of fun that can be had without
taking on unnecessary what happened to
that pizza company
uh i think they're still in engineering
risk mode they got like a big contract
from domino's but then their ceo got
was in trouble for some things that they
hired a new ceo something something
something
you know like again these are legit
engineering risks so i'm not like that
doesn't mean they'll all work
but like what i'm doing with the
newsletter is like neither technical
risk nor market risk yeah operational
risk it's just are you gonna are you
gonna be able or wanting to do it for a
long time which is yeah we're just like
you know that's a pretty good thing to
try to overcome
right yeah it's really tough you know i
remember coming to san francisco and
and hearing all these narratives and
these bc's telling me this and also
entrepreneurs sort of repeating a lot of
this stuff
and
i will say it
it's tough to go against
what
these stamps of approvals say to do you
know like you have to tell yourself
every day like and i have to do that too
like
when i started a services business all
my most of my silicon valley friends
were like a services business like an
agency
that's what you're gonna do
after you know like
and you just kind of have to push
forward and really just
um remember that
you know just because some you know
certain people on twitter say a certain
thing or or or sequoia or andreessen say
a certain thing doesn't mean
um
you can't have a great like i would say
you can have a better lifestyle not
being mark zuckerberg than being mark
zuckerberg
yeah
exactly
[Music]
you